bienvenue à la facture si vous cherchez
un plombier d'urgence vous irez sans
doute sur internet mais attention parce
que certains sites se présentent comme
des entreprises de plomberie mais dans
son pas et bien des gens s'en sont rendu
compte trop tard
nous sommes chez portes et moulures
dépôt à Longueuil l'été dernier la
toilette du magasin en débordé
Marie-Soleil Robitaille une employée et
Yves Dion le gérant de la succursale
était là heureusement un service
d'urgence était disponible Java appelé
d'autres numéros avant trop occupés trop
occupés trop occupé répond pas le
filament quand j'étais tombé sur ce
téléphone là j'étais comme content
deux hommes de l'entreprise plombier
urgence se sont présentés au magasin
mais Yves a dû quitter la succursale
avant qu'ils aient fini le travail c'est
Mary soleil qui était chargé de payer
les plombiers il m'avait parlé en 340
et 500 dans le maximum 500 qui m'avait
dit au téléphone ils nous une assurance
de 5 ans à 25 dollars le déplacement de
base à 275 trois heures à 275 dollars
la machine riz à 300 dollars le matériau
467 et 12 pour une pièce 99 total de la
facture
2175 dollars et c'est vraiment ridicule
arnaquer comme ça
est-ce que la réparation a été bien
faite au moins non pas du tout le
lendemain que je suis arrivé la senteur
était Térée dans chambre de bain ça fait
que oui j'ai fait revenir un autre
plombier un employé a publié un
commentaire sur Google contre plombier
urgence attention arnaque puis Yves Dion
et son équipe sont passés à autre chose
ils n'ont donc pas vu qu'un mois plus
tard une alerte était publiée par la
Corporation des maîtres mécaniciens en
tuyauterie qui encadre plusieurs
entrepreneurs spécialisés dont les
plombiers on a reçu plusieurs plaintes
dans un cours laps de temps et on a pu
faire des liens dans les situations qui
nous étaient dénoncées c'était souvent
des situations dans lesquelles il y
avait exécution de travaux de plomberie
dans un contexte d'urgence on nous
dénonçait des coûts excessifs une
pression indus pour obtenir le paiement
selon le communiqué Laurie bois et une
entreprise à numéro faisant affaire sous
plusieurs noms sont soupçonnés
d'exercices illégal de la plomberie
nous avons fait des recherches sur
chacun de ces noms et numéros
les informations trouvées nous ont
permis de faire des liens entre Lorie
bois et trois autres personnes grâce à
des numéros de téléphone des adresses et
des noms qui réfèrent à plusieurs
secteurs d'activité
dans cet enchevêtrement digne d'une
toile d'araignée seul le riz bois est
visé par la CMMTQ ce qui est plus
difficile dans un cas comme ça c'est de
faire les recherches pour nous amener à
trouver la preuve contre les véritables
personnes qui sont derrière
l'ensemble de ces informations là
sont par le début nous appelons le
ribois elle refuse de nous donner une
entrevue à la caméra mais accepte de
nous parler elle affirme qu'elle
appelait des non coupable aux
accusations qui pèsent contre elles
[Musique]
comment
selon elle celui qui dirige les
activités de l'entreprise est une autre
personne sur notre tableau Cédric brazot
son ex-conjoint il y a eu des
condamnations envers un individu du nom
de Cédric Alexandre brazot verratti en
2018 alors pour l'exécution de travaux
de plomberie et chauffage donc en 2018
il y a eu deux condamnations contre cet
individu toutefois aucune accusation ne
pèse contre Cédric Brazeau aujourd'hui
les faux plombiers sur internet ce n'est
pas nouveau c'est un phénomène que
Myriam Hertz connaît bien elle est
professeur spécialisée en marketing
numérique à l'Université du Québec à
Chicoutimi c'est un phénomène qui est
assez ancien pour commencer qui est
apparu aux États-Unis et principalement
dans le Canada anglophone donc l'idée
c'est de d'avoir une présence sur
Internet pour attirer en fait le
consommateur à partir du moment où on
est dans un sentiment d'urgence on
réfléchit parfois plus de manière 100%
rationnelle donc c'est à ce moment là
que heure rentre en jeu puisque eux
proposent en fait un service qui va
répondre à cette urgence mais qui va
profiter de la situation
de vulnérabilité de la personne parce
qu'elle est dans cette situation
d'urgence
en créant des sites internet de toutes
pièces et en les positionnant en tête
des résultats de recherche grâce à
l'achat de mots clés ces individus
captent la clientèle à la recherche
d'entrepreneurs spécialisés c'est
surtout dans certains domaines comme la
plomberie de la serrurerie donc
justement là où il y a il peut y avoir
des demandes Express d'urgence pour
ensuite se rendre directement auprès du
consommateur et lui rendre un mauvais
service ou
exagérer les réparations faire de la
casse de manière délibérée pour ensuite
surfacturer et amener donc le
consommateur à payer beaucoup plus cher
que ce qu'il aurait payé avec un service
normal si on peut dire
et quand le client veut savoir qui est
derrière l'entreprise il en est
incapable il dit Dion a tenté de se
faire rembourser mais plombier urgence
n'a jamais retourné ses appels avec
l'aide de ses collègues il a mené sa
petite enquête et a trouvé plusieurs
adresses et c'est d'abord rendu à celle
qui est indiquée sur sa facture ça
donnait à nos wher
nous dans le fond qu'est-ce qu'on veut
qu'on recherchait là
en espérant de voir le troc à une de ses
adresses-là même à l'adresse de la
compagnie à numéro qui a perçu le
paiement c'est d'être l'adresse qui est
lourd enroule pas de plombier on était
voir en arrière pour justement boire le
fameux pick-up blanc puis on a on a rien
vu bonjour monsieur est-ce que je peux
vous parler une seconde mais ici le
locataire nous a montré du courrier
adressé à leur ibois donc revenons à
notre tableau l'entreprise de leuribois
service urgence qui est maintenant radié
est lié à plombier urgence
mais qui est au nom de Stéphanie Provost
quant à l'adresse internet elle a été
associée à Cédric brazot et à une autre
entreprise
urgence 24,7 qui elle est au nom de
Maxime Marquette le conjoint de
Stéphanie Provost
nous avons parlé à une dizaine de
clients de lune ou l'autre de ces
entreprises ils estiment tous avoir été
mal servi surfacturé voire arnaquer et
surtout incapable de retrouver les
responsables par la suite deux clients
ont voulu porter plainte à la police
sans succès parce que selon Myriam Hertz
départager la fraude du simple mauvais
service n'est pas facile pour les
policiers
c'est sûr qu'il y a des fraudeurs purs
mais après il y a aussi tout tout le
volet un peu plus
un peu moins clair ou on a des
entreprises qui sont pas tout à fait
dans l'illégalité mais qui ont des
pratiques qui sont en tout cas non
éthiques c'est pas nécessairement un
crime et il faut vraiment que un
consommateur en fait commence par
engager des poursuites judiciaires et
qui en est plusieurs qu'il fasse pour
que par la suite il y a une réaction de
la justice et de la police envers
l'organisation en question nous avons
voulu savoir quel est le rôle de
Stéphanie Provost et Maxime Marquette
tous les deux refusent de nous
rencontrer et se disent victimes de leur
ibois et Cédric Brazeau ils affirment
eux aussi avoir servi de prêtres non
après plusieurs tentatives
nous finissons par rejoindre Cédric
brazot au téléphone
moi ce que je fais c'est de la publicité
ok je suis pas
bosses tu es déjà
accusé présentement là par la
Corporation des maîtres mécaniciens de
Québec
à 100%, je pense vraiment que l'histoire
que toutes les Allemands est pas la
bonne histoire
mais nous n'en serons pas davantage
parce que cette nuit là Cédric brazot a
été arrêté par la police relativement de
nombreuses accusations criminelles
notamment pour voie de fait et vol
contre le ribois il est présentement
détenu
qui dit vrai dans toute cette histoire
difficile de le savoir mais actuellement
des sites Internet liés à ces quatre
personnes sont toujours actifs et un
autre site vient d'apparaître il se
positionne en tête des résultats de
recherche sur Google sur cette page
plusieurs faussetés et au bout du fil
surprise
qui répond
le ribois n'a pas voulu nous dire pour
qui elle travaille actuellement si vous
avez eu des problèmes vous aussi ou si
vous avez d'autres informations
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter et si
vous êtes à la recherche d'un plombier
La CMMTQ vous suggère de faire vos
recherches dans son répertoire des
membres plutôt que sur Google les
détails sur notre site internet